look there is a riot that occurred at
the Capitol and so you know what do we
need to talk about there it's the same
thing that I said after day one you know
day one which was look there was Intel
that that we knew about that's now
you're you're starting to see some of
that come out Pelosi knew about it the
Democrats knew about it that's why the
the Trump Administration uh was willing
to have National Guard ready for the
capital That's Not Unusual it happens
when you have big protests especially or
when you're getting ready to to have an
inauguration it was the first time that
I'd never seen I mean they put up the
fences for anything right I I was there
for two decades I mean oh my God there's
gonna be a protest of Supreme Court boom
they do like a double fence if anybody's
if you've been to Washington DC the
Supreme Court's essentially right across
from the capitol they'll put like double
fences up get plenty of security that's
just for a supreme court protest that
you know some you know with for a few
hundred people so the fact that they had
the intelligence they had approval for
the National Guard there was no fencing
put up and now the way that they're
going about all this when you got this
guy
uh you know so it really appears like
Russia hoax 3.0 it's just like another
version of it
all right so before we dive into the
tech stuff and sort of what shifted you
in your career and all that you know I
have spent literally zero cumulative
minutes talking about January 6th on my
program to me it is a complete
distraction it is it is impeachment
number three it is going to end with
nothing going anywhere it's going to
make a set of sort of very confused
people about the principles of America
even more confused but because you've
been in this with Trump for a while
because you've been trying to fight this
information because you were involved
you know around the the impeachment
trial and all those things is there
anything you'd like to just say about it
broadly or specifically uh because I
just feel that I have no need to
entertain this that's really just how I
feel about it yeah well I think you're
you're you're right to not entertain it
I think kind of my my quick thoughts are
this the institution uh in Congress uh
and all the institutions in Washington
um are collapsing all right so kind of
what we just talked about with
California it's happening in our
nation's capital also and what I say is
we've just entered a a dark chapter of
American History right now that started
in that
2015-16 time frame with the first that
first piece being that
that people within the FBI and doj
thought it was perfectly okay to get
involved in politics and frame a
presidential candidate and ultimately
the entire Republican party so it
started with oh it's a dirty trick get
the FBI to participate in it get get
informants to participate uh walk all
this stuff into the FBI and the doj in
different locations like what came out
in the in the recent Sussman trial uh
fully engaged the fake news media with
it
um you know but but at the time they
just Justified it in their own mind uh
well it's just uh it's just Donald Trump
so you know nobody cares about that
let's just you know write crap about
them and crap about them and crap about
them and first it started as well let's
just call them uh that he has ties to
Russian oligarchs and then suddenly they
move that because there were no ties to
Russian oligarchs and say well what the
hell let's just say he has ties to Putin
because they knew that Hillary Clinton's
emails they were afraid that by the way
they never actually came out the emails
that the Congress had an actual
investigation going on to because she
destroyed a server and a legal server
you know taking you back to that time
right yeah so from there it just got
worse right the and I you know I was the
one who essentially came out like
essentially on day one or you know
probably day you know second or third
week and I said Russia stuff what the
hell are you guys talking about like I
was just like six months prior to this
you Obama and your whole crew wouldn't
do a damn thing about Putin as he
invaded Crimea he was involved in Libya
he was involved in Syria and we won't
get into foreign policy discussion here
today but I knew it was
you know pure utter I think I can say
[ __ ] on your show you can say it so
I knew it was total [ __ ] because
you know I knew because as the chairman
of the in-house intelligence committee I
knew what they weren't doing
so you can't come you know come out
right after the election we were told
hey nothing unusual yeah Putin's a thug
he's a bad guy he he messes around I
mean it's not unusual for him to mess
around in elections but you know all
they really found at the end of the day
that Putin did was you know he bought a
few Facebook ads which by the way
weren't even in the states that that
mattered right so that was the extent of
of actual hard evidence that we had on
the intelligence committee we didn't
have anything else and that was the
position of the officials in the FBI uh
and and the other intelligence agencies
that we worked with until they decided
to turn on the operation so they did
they ran a dirty trick all through the
campaign and then they just doubled down
with the full power of the FBI and doj
and you know the rest and I had to take
the you know the brunt of that we
exposed it all
um then it led to Mueller uh the Mueller
investigation total corruption right
they couldn't find you know they they
couldn't find anything on Russia but
they found plenty of process crimes that
they went after people on we had you
know I had to sit out there every single
day you know how hard it is
when you've got 95 percent of the media
that is listening to Democrats in
Congress and people within within the
former Intel people current Intel people
Mill you know retired four-star generals
you know who would constantly come out
and say well I can't tell you what I
know but it's really bad right and I had
to sit there and say no you guys are
lying right and you're totally full of
it so you know I had to sit there and
withstand that so that Mueller hoax and
then it goes into impeachment you know
the whole Ukraine impeachment was a
whole nother debacle and then it and and
then look there was a riot that that
occurred at the Capitol and so you know
what do we need to talk about there it's
the same thing that I said after day one
you know day one which was look there
was Intel that that we knew about that's
now you're you're starting to see some
of that come out Pelosi knew about it
the Democrats knew about it that's why
the the Trump Administration uh was
willing to to have National Guard ready
for the capital That's Not Unusual it
happens when you have big protests
especially or when you're getting ready
to to have an inauguration it was the
first time that I'd never seen I mean
they put up the fences for anything
right I was there for two decades I mean
oh my God there's gonna be a protest of
Supreme Court boom they do like a double
fence if anybody's if you've been to
Washington DC the Supreme Court's
essentially right across from the
capitol they'll put like double fences
up get plenty of security that's just
for a supreme court protest that you
know some you know with for a few
hundred people
so the fact that they had the
intelligence they had approval for the
National Guard there was no fencing put
up and now the way that they're going
about all this when you got this guy
uh you know so it really appears like
Russia hoax 3.0 it's just like another
version of it you've got this guy Ray
Epps who clearly was inciting people uh
the guy is not even being arrested uh
he's not even being interviewed I mean
nobody just seems to know anything about
him the dudes that living out in Arizona
I mean you know just that's just one
example of what appears like there was
some type of federal involvement in in
instigating in you know instigating the
riot so and when I say the riot it
should not be hard there's some 14
000 hours of videotape that I have
called for for the last you know when I
was in Congress and now now and and even
today like release it they won't even
show the Republicans the videotape right
so they're selectively showing showing
tape and there's cameras all over the
capitol Dave that just so you know I
mean it's there's plenty of video
because of of however you know we never
even got the exact number of how many
people went into the capital but what
I've said from from from day one is
release the videotape and the people
that I want busted and prosecuted are
the ones who were fully masked up they
somehow had exactly the location to go
to and they exactly the tools they
needed to break windows
and to this day I'm not sure I could be
wrong I mean it changes every day but
I'm not sure they have located those
what appear to be maybe two to three
dozen people at different doors that
broke those windows I mean those people
should be prosecuted the full extent of
the law we still don't even know who the
hell they are I sense those what they're
saying subtly is that they might be feds
right
I don't know who the hell they are we
don't know I mean I I mean I know that
Epps guy I mean that's clearly fishy
right I mean he's living out in Arizona
somewhere and I mean hell the night
before he's on videotape with with
people you know uh Trump supporters that
were out there for the rally which by
the way the idea that Trump but
president Trump or anyone else would
hold a rally on our nation's Mall in
Washington DC that's only out of the
norm when Trump does it right I mean
there are rallies there I was just there
I mean this past weekend they had the
pride rally and they had some gun rally
I think last time I was in I was in
Washington DC they had a
uh they had like a police officer's uh
uh for fallen police officers rally so
the idea that it's like unusual somehow
that the the people can have rallies
um I mean that's at the Cornerstone of
our of our Democratic Republic here
right and if you go back just you know
four or five six months before you had
BLM riots who destroyed the capital shut
it down I damn near got attacked you
know coming out of the when Trump gave
his nomination speech in Washington DC
just months before so you know the idea
that suddenly now oh you you can't have
a rally it's it's that's nonsense okay
so I just go back to what crimes were
broken well clearly the people who broke
the windows the rest of the people I
mean a lot of people had no clue that
they couldn't go into the capitol
because look the capital is normally
open for the public except when like
during covid when Pelosi has you know
closed it down so so I just go back to
release the damn videotapes tell me what
did Pelosi know when did she know it
um let's find out who you know who are
these guys like Epps there's several of
them who broke the windows that's where
you need to start but like going after
people who were just out there pissed
off about the election I mean you know
let's not forget we're still you still
have people who have not accepted the
election for 2016 because they believe
that Trump and Putin and Russia all
stole this why because these Liars
like Pelosi and others told the American
people that the media went along with it
and they brainwashed people all over
this country so anyway that's all I have
for January 6th I yearn I yearn for
those good old days those good old days
of 2017 when Hillary was allowed to
tweet that Donald Trump is an
illegitimate president and it would not
get taken down from Twitter when Stacey
Abrams would say she won the
gubernatorial race in Georgia and it
would not get taken down you used to be
able to question these things if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell